men and women aren't equal and it's a
feature not a bug cancelled
i think there's a massive war on
masculinity right now the patriarchy is
dead we live in a matriarchy i believe
feminism was created by the men at the
top because they wanted to have a 50 of
the population that they could tax so
they could make more money they want
women out of the home into the workplace
so now the children are left to hoot the
state easier to indoctrinate easier to
brainwash i think there's a greater
agenda at play here which is in charge
of all of this what's the idea um the
agenda is control there's literally an
account on twitter clown world all it
that uses is two emojis it just retweets
things that other people are putting out
in the world and just says this is
insane with everything going on in the
world right now coverts vaccines the war
and masculinity feminism going crazy has
woken people up and that's why i'm so
excited about bitcoin this is a way for
people to opt out of all this [ __ ]
which is only going to get worse all
right guys bang bang i've got leah here
uh i'm super excited about this i
thought a great place to start would be
a war on men and feminism is a scam
which i've heard you say multiple times
uh what exactly does that mean well
firstly thanks for having me super
excited to be here um yeah i mean i
think there's a massive war on
masculinity right now but i think it's a
war which has been going on for a very
long time i mean you only need to look
at like media headlines for example they
say if a man wants to be fit and strong
he's suddenly right-wing um i've seen
that everywhere um they talk about um
you know jim bros being dumb and all
this stuff um you know you're also now
sort of encouraging men to um to cry and
to do all these emotional things um you
know and i think it's both genders to be
honest i think they're trying to mask
make women more masculine and make men
more feminine um and
there are many different reasons why
this might be and we can get into that
but it's so toxic
you know if a man is brave and strong
suddenly that's toxic masculinity if a
man wants to you know provide for his
family and he's gone every day or
whatever it is that's toxic masculinity
um but what i find really fascinating
about the entire thing is the fact that
when it comes to equality and wanting
you know both wanting quotas to get an
equal amount of men and women in
whatever kind of workspace there is you
never hear anything about um you know
plumbers
builders you don't want more female
builders never hear that it's always we
need more you know more women in and all
this stuff so there's i mean you must
feel it as a man you must feel like you
know there are certain things in certain
places in the states that you're sort of
like not allowed to behave in a certain
way i don't know do you ever feel that
way i i always go to uh just like
personal experience and the one area
that uh was taboo for a really long time
for people to talk about and all that
stuff and then like now somehow i was
coming to the conversation it's the
military and so like in the infantry uh
for the longest time there was no women
in the infantry and the thought process
was like one uh just like really close
quarters there's like a lot of uh
interpersonal things you can imagine if
soldiers are on the battlefield uh you
know and there's men and women and uh in
these kind of like high combat areas and
stuff like it throws off a lot of the
cohesiveness of the unit not necessarily
for good or bad it's just it's different
uh two though and like where i've always
thought about it is like
if i was on the battlefield
and i've got i don't know 60 70 80 100
pounds of gear on
there are not very many women if any
woman yeah who at the time when i got
deployed i think i was like a 200 pounds
195 pounds she's about 300 pounds are
they gonna pick me up and put me on
their shoulder and carry me off if i'm
wounded yeah exactly by the way
there wasn't a [ __ ] ton of men who could
do it either there were some but guess
what they had to do is then they had to
drag they had to do like all these
different things and so like you start
to understand like okay to your point
about like plumbers or like physical
labor or whatever like i haven't seen a
lot of conversation around let's get
more women to go to the oil fields and
like move the machinery around one two
because like they pick and choose what
suits them which also like leads onto
the whole feminism topic and we can get
to that but you had obviously andrew
tate recently on your show and andrew
talks about a lot of harsh realities
which i think are so important i know
this is really harsh what i'm gonna say
but it's a truth which i've sort of
learned by being on the internet too
long um but there's this idea that as a
man no woman other than your mother is
gonna love you unconditionally
and that is what andrew talks about
that's what like the red pill space
talks about and that is so powerful so
it means okay as a man how do you get a
woman to love you how do you get society
to respect you you literally need to
become women can just be men have to
become so you have to make money it's
not all about money but it's about
status it's always about status
unfortunately or whatever unfortunately
so if we look at men in general right uh
let's use the united states as kind of
this example like what is in your mind
uh society's vision of like the perfect
man right like what does that look like
today in today's society it's a good
question because i think today's society
we have a lot of like fem-centric
systems whether it's like the education
system um the judiciary system they're
all fem centered so
what does that mean femme centered it
means that it's women who are raising
men or like teaching boys so you have
more um more female teachers in schools
and they say to boys it's okay to cry
it's okay you know they're not teaching
them mental resilience and and how to
become a strong man how to become a
strong adult um you know the judiciary
system if for if a man and a woman are
together they're married and um you know
say she cheats or whatever it is they
get divorced she gets half his money and
the kids you know it's very sem femme
centric um and so it's the woman that's
in charge we keep talking about like um
you know the patriarchy the patriarchy
is dead we live in a matriarchy whereby
men i think get the brunt of everything
i don't think even marriage is a good
deal for men either why not
for what i just said because of the
judiciary system um because like
basically in the in the downside case
the men get screwed exactly exactly
whereas a woman is always going to be
safe and also we have to consider how
men and women are viewed in society
again we talk about the so-called
patriarchy but it's women who are valued
more than men we want equality but like
what does equality even mean i think
women are intrinsically valued on a
higher level to men because it's the
women and the children that are always
protected first it's the men that are
sent off to war it's the men that are
more disposable
as a man like i said you have to become
and a woman can just be so it's like
society doesn't care about you until you
become something um and nobody wants to
talk about that and i think we should
talk about it the reason we should talk
about it is because i think the dynamics
between men and women would just be
better like i think that um with the
correct with healthy masculinity um
femininity can can thrive in that kind
of space
and if we stop men from being masculine
and we stop women from being feminine
the genders just
melt into each other and it becomes a
mess and there's a lot of toxicity and
so nobody wants to talk about the fact
that men are disposable in this world
well there's obviously the old like
phrase you know uh hard times make
strong men and and kind of go the whole
thing and eventually what you get is
good times and good times make weak men
and weak men make hard times um and so
when we think about that is that just
like a natural cycle that we've seen
throughout civilizations or is this
something new where american society is
uh
taking the idea of what it is to be a
man and changing it or have we seen in
the past after the roman empire fell
like was there some point in time where
uh no men were supposed to cry and do
all these different things because it
was no longer about uh kind of the
dominance of kind of ancient rome or is
this something that you think is brand
new i think there's two
pivotal parts in modern day i mean i'm
only in my 20s so i can't think too far
back but let's just take the 60s right
the 60s is an amazing example because
that was basically the liberation of
women um that's basically when women
didn't need men right it's it's feminism
because feminism empowers women um
what is feminism
which wave
i don't know you tell me feminism
ultimately if you speak to a feminist
she's going to say oh it's about the
equality of men and women i don't think
it is anymore it's about the woman's
right to choose her own destiny and i
think that's i think that's important i
think that's great um you know i clearly
have my own career or whatever but
that's because i believe in individual
empowerment i think everybody should be
um empowered to save themselves as a
woman you shouldn't rely on
a husband you shouldn't rely on the
government you shouldn't rely on daddy
whatever you need to be empowered
because you don't know what's coming
tomorrow right what if your husband dies
what if you're you know whatever
um and so that's essential
but we're now at a point whereby
feminism i think has gone too far
so
um you know if you hold the door for a
man oh sorry if a man holds the door for
you what are you doing i can hold my own
door um and like these these things are
so integrated into society i'm from
london and when i was 21 i used to work
as a journalist and i carried all this
heavy equipment by myself on the london
underground up and down the stairs not
one man ever offered to help me because
he was i could see it they looked at me
but oh should i should i not should i
i'm like yes help me i'm a little woman
it's okay i'm not offended right um but
they never did because they were um
afraid that they would offend me um and
i think feminism has gone too far it's
now rejecting um the feminine they're
trying to say well you know what is it
why is why is soft and nurturing
feminine because it is and that's okay
um so i feel like they are rejecting
that um and we sort of spoke about
earlier but there's like this pendulum
that's going on and i think we've gone
way too far one way um and now the likes
of like andrew tay and you know this
kind of content are pushing people the
other way and making people more
comfortable about talking about these
things i also think the reason why i'm
so vocal about this some people say to
me are you doing it for clicks you're
doing it because it's a really good
niche it's not true like i want to get
married like i'm single i want to get
married and i want to find a masculine
man you know
and
that's and and so that's hard because
there aren't so many masculine men left
because they don't know how to be
because of the fem-centric systems that
we spoke about um you know it's okay to
cry it's okay to that like the fact of
the matter is your wife doesn't want to
see you cry she doesn't want to see you
struggle she all she wants is safety and
that's it so if you're looking weak
that's going to worry her and so the
respect for you declines and again
people don't like this reality but i
think these conversations are really
important i think that how much of this
is just society is getting softer
because of the good times uh versus it's
like a specific
male thing
it's a i think it's it's both parts so a
lot of people would say that um western
society peaked in the 90s um and then
after 9 11 and you know
all the surveillance came in and
everything like that that sort of where
it went downhill and i can see that as
well i can see that with my own family
my own parents like they have this idea
that you know if you work a good job and
um you know you get your good grades you
get a good job and you work your way up
and you know you work for the man then
you know you're going to have a nice
retirement to come back to and all of
that and i think
now is the first time we saw that really
truly play out in the 20th century right
in modern day times we saw that really
truly play out and now we're sort of
realizing that actually that's not the
case
and so it's the realization that you
need more you need a backup plan can i
remember your first question what was
your first question when you think about
society in general right it's very
obvious
males are being pushed to be softer in
whatever way you want to measure that
and to some degree people who are
pushing back on that um we can argue
over the last five years they probably
were getting uh uh kind of shunned by
society hey what are you talking about
a lot of the labels come out that people
start to use to try to put them in a box
so that other folks won't listen to them
or whatever
but also i think that it's bigger than
just
male right i think that
in general society has gotten much much
softer and i always talk about like
there's like a mental toughness crisis
in america yeah of just like
shut up and deal with the problems and
that's not a man saying that it's not a
woman saying that that's just like how
the world works
and uh what you do see is in many great
societies uh they go through this uh
kind of rise of the empire uh the good
times are really [ __ ] good they're
amazing people absolutely love them
but it does cause a lot of problems and
then naturally there's a decline of the
empire we've seen this time and time
again in history
and it's hard this is not just in
countries like this is also true of
companies right i always talk about the
fact that like bill gates used to be you
know the pirate in the garage like bill
gates is gonna take down you know ibm or
whoever any and he's the renegade
now bill gates is the man
he is literally the institution right
and so like if you live long enough you
move from the like incumbent or i'm
sorry from the disrupter to the
incumbent and so like countries do this
companies do this but like also to some
degree like how many people are kind of
renegades as individuals who make big
bold bets who are willing to dream and
have the courage and conviction to take
risks and do all stuff when they're
young and still at the age of 60 are
doing the same thing
like even humans themselves you grow way
more risk averse you're you you lose
some of the kind of
mental flexibility or intellectual
flexibility you have and like that is
just the nature of uh of kind of how the
world works
we actually celebrate people who don't
like elon musk sold a company took all
the money and just like put it on black
basically said i'm a bet on myself i'm
gonna go invest in these three companies
and maybe i go broke yeah he's not
supposed to do that like society says
like that was dumb
now he looks pretty smart but like for
the most part a lot of people still even
though knowing that it worked think
that's insane and that's why those
stories go viral or or get celebrated
but you're like
maybe that is the way that the world
should work is that people should have
more boldness to them and have the
courage to take more risk yeah but they
wouldn't teach you that so you're asking
you know is this just a man thing or a
woman thing i think it's a system thing
so the 90s was the peak and then
everything kind of sort of came crashing
down
and i think there's a greater agenda at
play here which is in charge of all of
this what's the idea um the agenda is
control it's always control it's power
and that's it um and you know why would
they teach you to be an entrepreneur
they don't want you to be an elon musk
they hate elon musk why do they hate him
they're obsessed with this esg narrative
and yet he's literally doing tesla cars
how does that make sense he's literally
trying to um improve uh the human life
by uh extending it and to another planet
and all this and they don't like him he
paid the most taxes and that's still not
enough why because he is an example that
you can achieve and you can do more and
you can be better he also has multiple
women and multiple children because he
can right unethical not ethical it
doesn't really matter as long as
everybody involved knows the case and is
and is consensual and everything's fine
then whatever but ultimately why would
they teach you to take more risk it
doesn't make sense but i do think with
everything that's going on in the world
right now um covid and everything like
that we've sort of realized that
actually this idea that we had in the
20th century whereby you know have a
nice safety net everything's gonna be
okay actually isn't the best plan which
is why i love bitcoin because i'm like
well that's my safety net like that's
that's my that's my rainy day you know
when if i don't put an injection inside
my body and i want to protest like the
truck is in canada i don't have to worry
about my money being confiscated because
i hold bitcoin that's where like my
interest in bitcoin comes from i feel
like it's that safety it's me it allows
me to be sovereign whether i need to
flee a country um because of a lockdown
and whatever it is you know i'm
obviously here not in london anymore um
that was very easy for me because you
know my bitcoins just just wherever it
is and i can just move that and so i
think that with everything going on in
the world right now covert vaccines the
war and masculinity feminism going crazy
rejecting whatever it means to be um
soft and feminine has woken people up
and has pushed them completely the other
way and i'm really excited and i think
as well like back in 2000 and was it 15
when trump won the election
people didn't expect him to win and i
was in university at the time and my
lecturer um who was just a very typical
um you know
professor lefty and all this i said to
her
trump's to win and she was like oh no he
won't absolutely not laughing at me very
posh hourly crack yeah um and i said
you'll see you'll see and of course he
won because people are fed up people are
tired um and that's why i'm so excited
about bitcoin like i don't care about
the price i just know that this is a way
for people to opt out of all this
[ __ ] which is only gonna get worse i
mean
2030 you'll have what is it you'll own
nothing and be happy what the hell is
that like how do you like how do you how
do you sit still and just be like oh
okay i'll own nothing and be happy i
think a lot about uh the difference
between like i call it like the
boardroom or the street right so and the
boardroom is really just a way to
describe like the mainstream talking
points the institutions like all the
things that are associated with people
wearing suits and ties to work doing
what they're supposed to do work at a
company for 40 years like all of these
things that our grandparents or parents
probably did because there was really no
other option they didn't know that um
and they just kind of passed along and
that's just what people were supposed to
do but then like the streets or the
street knowledge it's really the
internet now yeah and uh there's a whole
collection of people and it's growing
bigger and bigger every single day who
are like this is insane like what is
going on there's literally an account on
twitter clown world that has like 250
000 followers that grew in i don't know
a year or so and all it uses is two
emojis
it uses a clown face and it uses a world
emoji and it just retweets things that
other people are putting out in the
world and just says this is insane it
says with two emojis and it's like how
powerful of an idea to simply just like
put a mirror up to the insanity and just
say to everyone like
this this is what you guys agree with
and so when you start to look at this
what
going to this like pendulum idea it used
to be
uh very much kind of on a hyper
masculinity um a very self-sovereign
type approach uh families had a very uh
kind of nuclear basis and and were very
interested in what they were supposed to
do and how that worked it swung
completely in the other direction and uh
you could argue that many times it swung
not because there was like some evil
secret plan i think a lot of times
people just hey there's a problem and
like we want to try to address the
problem it was good intentions
but the pendulum swung pretty far and
you can look at the safety in cities you
can look at family uh kind of dynamics
you can look at all these different
things
but to your point it feels like it's
coming back and now people are like this
is [ __ ] insane and one of the things
that i use as a proxy for this is when i
see things go viral what's the message
because the something that goes viral
really goes viral for one of two reasons
either everyone's like yes this like
like this i resonate with this like uh
is something that i agree with or
oh my god look how crazy this person is
like this is insanity whatever
in both of those cases now like i've
actually seen over the last i don't know
six weeks eight weeks
multiple videos of women saying a lot of
what you're saying in terms of like the
uh kind of feminist movement is like
dumb essentially
i didn't see that two years ago and so
it does feel like there's like this
pendulum swinging but like what was the
catalyst why do you think the pendulum
is now swinging back in the other
direction i think it's because we've
given people enough time like we tried
it we tried the left-wing thing we tried
women dying their hair blue not shaving
their armpits did it get them a
high-value man no it didn't um and then
also as more people grow up they start
to
come into themselves more right so like
i'm in my mid-20s when i was 19
20 i was like a real tomboy like i was
quite masculine like i loved wrestling
and things like that as i grow up i
become more feminine and i i enjoy more
feminine things like you'll not see me
in like trousers nowadays like i don't
like that i want to wear dresses like
you just feel it within you right
and it's just a feeling and you just
want to reject what they're trying to do
to you um whether it's you know cut your
hair short dye your hair blue piercings
like it just doesn't work and the older
you get the more you learn more about
yourself and different situations that
you prefer
um and that sort of i think it just
takes time like we tried we tried the
other way women aren't happy we're
seeing women who are you know amazing in
their careers but they're single in
their 30s it's not really happiness like
i know as a matter of fact if i like i
would rather and i'm going to say this
here i would rather
um
be so happily married and satisfied in a
marriage then be
the best ceo the best whatever it is
because i know that it doesn't work it's
that's not where happiness comes from
and the older i get the more i
understand that as a woman and i think a
lot of women are understanding that too
um and it's also because it went so far
the other way and so
girls are like i can't i don't resonate
with that what do you mean you don't
shave your armpits why wouldn't you
shave your armpits you know they don't
resonate with that um is that is that
what the conversation that girls have
with each other is like do you shave
your armpits not really no
but it's like but it's but well actually
i used to when i was working in london
as a journalist i was working with this
girl i was 21 she was 25 at the time um
and she said to me she doesn't shave her
armpits and i was like i was like why
she said i want to just reject it i'm
like what would you mean reject it
why is that the thing like there's a lot
of other things there because it's okay
for a man to be hairy but it's not okay
for a woman to be hairy and why why is
femininity why is a woman valuable if
she's soft like a baby you know isn't
that isn't that disgusting isn't that
like pedophilia like you know so it's
the same as like men liking younger
women why she looks like a baby that
must mean men are evil they don't like
mature older women who are actual adults
it's all rubbish because we understand
why men like younger women and why women
date
older men but you also mentioned the
clown world thing which i just wanted to
touch on you said there might be because
of the pendulum but i actually think
it's more sinister than that okay
um the drag queen story hour thing is so
messed up i really really believe that
like the powers that be whether it's you
know biden the administration all these
things that they're supporting um i
think they're doing it for a bad reason
i don't know what that reason is i
imagine it's probably to destabilize
society destabilize the dynamics between
men and women so we don't have that
nuclear family anymore so children grow
up unstable and unable to fight
whatever's coming that's my arch my
overall view but it's so sinister how
like how on what planet can you justify
drag queens twerking in front of
children i saw a video of a drag queen
on stage um somewhere in america
inviting a child she looked at least 10
years old to come up on stage and twerk
with her how are people clapping in what
in what world is that even okay
gay pride has totally been um hijacked
and totally destroyed i have so many gay
friends and they don't resonate with it
their bitcoin is as well
well because
lgbtqq plus plus plus whatever is is all
uh the gay pride is just men walking
down streets half naked in bondage
whipping each other's bums while there's
children there
how does a gay person resonate with that
only somebody that's messed up in the
head would think yeah that's okay to do
that in public in front of children and
so the whole lgbt thing has been totally
hijacked and has been given the green
light by the powers that be
i can't remember who maybe it was like
was it eric adams or somebody probably
eric adams who said something really
positive about like drag queens and
children the other day and i'm like are
you insane yeah he he uh he's been a big
disappointment i mean that was obvious
though
across a couple of different uh uh
aspects the uh um talk about hoodwinking
a lot of people um and i've seen a lot
of folks who are very positive and very
supportive of him publicly not so much
anymore but they uh they don't have the
courage to come out and say it so they
kind of stay behind closed doors um but
but the whole thing with the drag queens
going into school i have a
nine-month-old daughter if she was in
school i don't even have to talk to my
wife like 100 she's getting pulled out
of school if she's going to school and
there's
drag
uh if there's twerking going on on stage
like
yeah just like stop [ __ ] with the
kids is kind of the way i think about it
um but it's not just that it's also this
idea of like i then extrapolated out and
i'm like okay if my daughter was
24 years old and she was like hey i'm
gonna bring my boyfriend home and she
walked through the door and there was
like some soft ass like [ __ ] boy
i would literally tell you i'm gonna
whoop this kid's ass right like i mean
that's just and again people get mad
whatever but like
that is the whole idea of like uh i i
think it's actually the exact same thing
that i would uh look at it from if i had
a son
and he brought home a girlfriend i would
be like yo
you have like a woman who isn't like a
strong woman who's going to be a good
partner for you in life i'd be like hey
man we gotta we gotta you know go on to
the next one here right like like
decision making it doesn't look so
strong and it's why i always go back to
like i actually think the number one
thing you could teach kids is just like
to be a good decision maker you're never
gonna be able to like okay here's every
single decision you're possibly gonna
have to make let me tell you all the
right moves like that's not how life
works but if you can just teach them
when you're faced with a decision like
here's how to think from first
principles here's how to think
critically here's how to think
independently like you you kind of go
through it you can then put them in all
these situations whether it's something
within their personal life and their
professional life whatever and you're
like they're at least armed with the
skills to like navigate the world with a
higher probability of success and they
are likely to avoid the really bad
decisions and that feels to me like as a
parent if you can do that then like you
at least set your kid up for success
doesn't guarantee but like you're much
better off than like let me just give
them to the state essentially and let
the state just like
i don't know teach them all kinds of
crazy [ __ ] but that's what's going on in
america more so in than in the uk and i
don't know enough about this but i know
there's like this push and pull between
parents and teachers and how much
control they have um and it's really
bizarre like that's also why feminism
okay so just to backtrack just a little
bit it's also why feminism even exists
in the first place like i believe
feminism was created by men by the men
at the top because they wanted to have a
50 of the population that they could tax
so they could make more money and then
also like i said destabilize the family
unit so they want women out of the home
into the career into the workplace so
now the women are sorry the children are
left
to who's going to take care of them the
state easier to indoctrinate easier to
brainwash um and only looking back now
at my childhood do i see the
indoctrination that i experienced um in
schools i like without getting too too
into it but like i come from a certain
culture and um
and i realized
now in hindsight i'm like oh wow they
were really trying to make us look at
look at that situation in that certain
way it wasn't until
i was in my 20s that i experienced a lot
more and i was like oh i actually don't
agree with that oh wow that's that's not
true it's like a religious thing or yeah
religious and cultural yeah yeah you
know they want you to support certain
ideas and they really shove that down
your throat as a child um it's why all
these ideas are shoved down your throat
as a child but that's not new right like
like take religion as one example i mean
you can go all the way back and like
there was no separation of state and and
uh god right like literally religion and
state were the same thing and so like
that was the dominant viewpoint there's
obviously been a decline in uh kind of
religious participation in the united
states and globally to some degree as
well but uh i i do wonder like how much
of that is just being replaced by like
the modern religion which we can talk
about you know is wokeness or religion
as an example yeah i think religion was
good like i think um all wars was always
going to happen people are always going
to hate each other religion is just a
scapegoat i think um like i was brought
up jewish and i i love judaism like it's
given me the best family values it's
stabilized me it's given me like
heritage and purpose and it's great i
think religion is great um i love
christians i love the christians in
america they have very amazing they're
very rude rooted they have great values
i get on with them very well
and so
religion gives people purpose it gives
people good values when you remove the
religion what is there where does your
hope come from when when life is tough
you don't have anyone to pray to you
don't have anything to ground you um and
so that's where i think like the victim
mentality and the wokeness started to
come from because it's like what else
are we going to need like we need
something to fulfill our minds because
you know good times create um hard good
men or whatever yeah so because times
were so easy
and there was a lack of religion
people's brains started to wonder it's
what we do we have to create problems
it's just how the mind works if it's
bored and i literally think wokeness was
born out of boredom and entitlement and
an easy time um which is why i think
people that's why we have social justice
warriors right because they need
something to feel good about because you
know they're not being a good jew or and
they're not being a good christian or
whatever muslim or whatever because you
know they don't have any religions they
have nothing to devote their life to
um you know family values are just gone
now so they don't have that really to to
ground them um so
all they have is this crisis that's
going on and of course they're lazy as
well because schools don't teach you how
to be better so they don't really have
like a career or anything um so they
they're just bored
and
looking for the next thing to the next
project you know the next thing to rile
them give them give them a sense of
something right like isn't everybody on
antidepressants these days so we're all
basically walking zombies right now and
so people need something to give them a
spark something to outrage them right
and so yeah if a woman sees a man that's
um that's talking the way andrew take
talks and he's saying you know women are
this you know i don't i don't want to be
with women who have slept with all these
men and they're like they're going to be
outraged because they need it i think
they need it really in order to like
survive
why did uh so many people go after
andrew tate i mean you've spent time
with them right i obviously uh did an
episode with them um and you know i said
to him at the end of the episode i said
look like the way that you deliver a lot
of the message uh is kind of in this
bombastic rapper and uh there's an
entertainment value to it but there's a
seat of truth in a lot of what he was
saying is it a thing where they feel
threatened by him they fear uh kind of
the truth getting out um what do you
think is going on there today's episode
is brought to you by ftx us they're a
safe regulated way to buy bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies they've got very cheap
fees sometimes as much as 85 cheaper
than their competitors there's also no
minimum fees there's no withdrawal fees
or any other hidden fees ultimately ftx
us is trying to make it dead simple for
you to buy bitcoin and cryptocurrencies
they also now have digital stock trading
as well with no transaction fees and no
payment for order flow all you have to
do is go download the ftx app today from
the app store and use code pop and
you'll get some money back every single
time you trade 10 or more again go
download the ftx app today use code pop
and every time you trade 10 or more
they'll go ahead and they'll give you
some crypto back the more you trade the
more you earn download the ftx app today
it's because he's literally the
anti-woke like he's the auntie of
everything that they're promoting so i
don't even think it has anything to do
with his um so-called misogynistic views
i don't really think they're
misogynistic but i don't think it has
anything to do with that i think it has
everything to do with the fact that he's
pulling people out of the matrix so he's
waking people up he's saying nobody's
coming to save you forget that nine to
five you need to save yourself you don't
need antidepressants let me teach you
how to fight depression by yourself what
does that do puts the pharmaceutical
companies out of out of work right and
so it's because he's literally
empowering men to save themselves and i
think that men are the forefront of
society like if you have weak men
society crumbles if you have strong
women it doesn't really matter it's the
men that matter so if you have strong
men then society can flourish in every
different way um and they don't want
with it like the powers that be don't
want us flourishing because less control
um and so like i personally learned so
much from him like i love
self-improvement content and so i'm i
mainly watch
men mail content to be honest because
it's mainly the men that are doing that
you know he talks about happiness and
again his content is for men but i like
it so he's like um
don't worry about being happy just wake
up get up and do keep going you know and
i'm like that's true i do i ask myself
am i happy what do i forget happiness
just do take action and that is so
powerful because
if you're not happy and you're wondering
why you're not happy all day you're just
going to be there taking your
antidepressants feeling like a zombie
demotivated compliant you'll do whatever
the system tells you to do you'll take
that vaccine because you can't be
bothered to fight because you have no
fight left in you so he's give he's he's
empowering people men in particular and
so they they can't allow that yeah if
you go back and you read uh the stoics
and then you listen to what andrew tate
was saying and you strip away the
delivery of both of them right so you
strip away kind of all of the uh poetic
uh um kind of almost to a degree
aristocratic you know uh
rapper from the stoics message and then
you take away the bombastic components
of andrew tate and and you overlay them
they're saying a lot of the same stuff
like you are in control you have to
mentally get into a certain position in
order to be successful in life uh
there's not a lot of like random
[ __ ] in the world and material
possessions and things like that that
will make you happy like ultimately it's
an inside job yeah right and what cracks
me up is i think that um if you were to
take also you know will smith who is
pretty well loved around the world
like he has a viral video uh where he
talks about like happiness is an inside
job and he explicitly says it's not my
job to make my wife happy it is her job
to be happy and somehow like that was
celebrated right and so like it's very
unique because i also think it
highlights this idea of like the
messenger
really matters um and one it's easy to
celebrate the dead people right because
it's like oh they're dead like they're
not they're not really threatening
anything exactly um two is they end up
getting shared by a lot of folks who we
consider of high status in society today
so when you see somebody tweeting about
the stoics reading books about the
stoics or whatever we end up ascribing
like oh you are of a certain status and
therefore those ideas
being shared by these people today mean
that these people are good and these
ideas are like accepted but then when
you see somebody who uh uh to the
outsider they'd be they would say what
has andrew tate accomplished the second
that it is uh kickboxing or it is you
know internet business or any of these
other things it doesn't fit into the
mold of uh oh you rose up in the ranks
in the corporation and he became the ceo
i actually would uh it would be
fascinating you can't study it or kind
of run the experiment but like what
happens if you took those exact same
thoughts and you had somebody from like
the accepted institutions say them what
would their response be for one people
would come for that person very quickly
because they'd have the pressures of the
institutions and so you can question
whether they'd ever even be able to say
this but
we do have some examples you look at
brian armstrong coinbase he comes out
he's like hey uh we have a business it's
a business we're capitalists we're here
to do work if you don't want to do work
then
you probably shouldn't be here if you're
worried about other things like go
somewhere else and i've told the story
before but uh during uh the pandemic uh
over the summer of 2020 there was all of
the social justice unrest and and uh all
that going on and i know two separate
ceos that run uh pretty large
fast-growing technology companies and
they were getting massive inbound people
were coming to them in their company and
saying why are we doing this why are we
doing this why and they were like in
private telling me like
i i don't know what to do like i
literally do not know what to do and so
both of them unbeknownst to each other
chose very similar paths one of them
uh they had a huge marketing campaign
that they had set up uh i think it was
like almost a million dollars or
something um and uh due to a couple of
things in the market and also uh just
sensitivities to kind of culture or
whatever they decided not to go for with
the marketing campaign but they had this
allocated money that was sitting there
so they had the idea let's give it to
the employees and we're going to give
the employees uh whatever it was
ten thousand dollars each or whatever
they can spend on whatever they want
you wanna buy a standing desk knock
yourself out you wanna get a gym
membership knock yourself out you wanna
pay off some student debt knock yourself
out if you want to donate the money
knock yourself out whatever
if you donate the money the ceo said i
will match up to 250 000 personally wow
and according to uh the ceo he had like
two people in the entire company donated
exactly everyone else took the money put
in their pocket now that doesn't mean
that uh they're wrong because that was
their right they could do whatever they
wanted with the money and and it doesn't
mean that they took the money and uh
just went out and you know uh spent it
at the club like maybe they actually did
pay off student loans or what nobody
knows but
the reason that they gave it was
everyone was requesting all these
different donations with the company's
money but then when it was their money a
little different story second guy almost
exact same thing gave everyone money
no cap
he just said hey
if you donate the money let me know and
i'll match it i'll match the whole thing
one person
and so again these are two anecdotes it
doesn't necessarily mean every company
would be this way but what i think it
showed was that like man when you kind
of almost like call their bluff there
wasn't a lot of action going on and then
i wonder if you take that and you
extrapolate it across all these issues
like how much of that is
the that's the standard that's the
default rather than these stories or
outliers yeah i literally think that's
the default like that's my issue with
socialism everybody's so generous with
other people's money but whenever it's
their own they're not which is why
whenever you find which is why they say
when you're younger if you're not a
democrat then you don't have a heart but
if you're older and you're still a
democrat then you don't have a brain
and it's because you know as you get
older and you make your own money um you
know me first charity starts at home i
mean how are you supposed to even i mean
it's the same with america how you
supposed to save yourself or save this
country if you keep giving money to
ukraine right like save your home first
charity starts at home so yeah people
are always going to be selfish first and
that's literally okay
um everybody's playing pretend that's
what i've noticed everybody's pretending
that pretending to be a good person they
prefer to pretend to be a good person
than actually be a good person
um like i help people i'm a nice person
um but like i don't need to tell people
i don't need to do anything about it and
actually
my way of helping people is tough love
like if you're fat i'm gonna tell you
you're fat and like i'm gonna tell you
like you're not gonna get a woman if you
behave like that you're not gonna get a
man if you behave like that like i'm
gonna tell you straight like the email
you sent me that crap
like to somebody obviously that's that i
know
um but you know i tell them like that's
not a good email like that's not going
to get you business and so people love
pretending everybody's pretending it's
why socialism is so stupid because so in
uh in the uk we have a lot of um
we have a lot of like nationalized
services right like um whether it's uh
houses whether it's our healthcare
system and all this um everything which
is nationalized and owned by the
government is honestly trash they trash
it because they don't care because it's
not theirs um that so that's my issue
with socialism everybody's so generous
with everyone else's money but as soon
as it's your money and somebody's
offering it to you you're gonna hold on
to that very very tight um but in terms
of the messenger that's a really good
point because um
it's interesting because jordan peterson
is also quite like andrew tay in terms
of
the message empowering men to be men and
i love jordan peterson like i'm such a
big fan um
but even they don't like him and he
comes from the institution he's a
professor he wears a three-piece suit
a yeah exactly you know he speaks
impeccably well everything about him you
know um you know he's got a great family
he's still with his wife he's not you
know messing around or anything like
that it's a great man and they hate him
because that's how deep the wokeness
goes it's the same as like um when i say
these things firstly i think i have
people give me more slack because i'm a
woman you know we live in such a
patriarchal society yeah i can get away
with saying more of these things um
because i'm a woman am i gonna be
careful when i go too far because i will
be banned um
but yeah you know it's why they hate
like black conservatives it's why when i
say what i say i get called a pick me
girl or uh what's that like i'm only
saying what i'm saying so a man will
pick me oh god yeah be picked you know
that rubbish um so they'll call me a
pick me rather than somebody who
actually thinks this like somebody on
crypto twitter for example um he
literally said that i say what i say um
because um i have internalized misogyny
um and i'm literally just trying to
please men that's why i say what i say
so a man was mansplaining to you right
yeah yeah kind of kind of part of the
joke exactly so i'm like you don't think
a woman can have an independent thought
you like
you know it's like it's like if a black
person's a conservative it's like you
know you know you're not black if you
don't vote for biden it's so insane
that's the internalized racism that's
the internalized misogyny so like you're
not allowed to um have your own opinion
and so the being a messenger a certain
type of messenger certainly helps like i
get a lot more
views or like more um
people caught me more slack as a woman
because they're like oh she said it then
you know i'm not at it as a man but she
can say it how do you use that like so i
i 100 agree that a woman can say certain
things that a man also could be saying
but for whatever reason uh it's almost
like a defense mechanism there's a lot
of folks in the political realm uh who
used to be democrats now they share more
kind of right-leaning uh uh theories and
one of the first offenses that everyone
will use is like oh well they used to be
a democrat then they like woke up right
or then then they did whatever and so
like they're cut slack because it's like
oh this person has actually changed
their mind uh how do you use that for
good or bad maybe uh being a woman
sharing some of the views that you have
what do you mean well just do you
intentionally go out and say like hey i
know i can say this and other people
can't so i'm going to say it or d or are
you just saying no look i just happen to
notice that people uh give me more slack
like is it an intentional thing or is it
more so it's just something that you've
noticed uh passively yeah it's not
calculated i don't say it because i'm a
woman and so i can i say it because i
genuinely mean it and i mean what i say
um and i can say a lot of things that
men can't say like i can say women are
emotional men can't say that but women
are so emotional um why why can you say
that in men because i'm a woman so i'm
allowed to right it's like a black
person's able to say like first i won't
comment on blm that much because like i
don't really want to i'm not black i'm
not getting into that i'll come on
women's stuff i don't really want to
like
step on things i'm not supposed to step
on whatever but is it also something
where you feel like you have uh more
insight into like the women's role in
society being a woman like i feel like i
it would be hard for me to comment on
like a woman's experience in society
because i'm not a woman
my wife would probably have a much
better idea of that than i would right
but you know the truth though like if
there's a problem between
in life and you and your wife are trying
to tackle it she's gonna tackle it more
emotionally than you would and she'd
probably rely on you for your logic and
your clear thinking i imagine yeah i
also think um one of the
pieces uh that really shocks me is just
how much uh like the idea of like this
like partnership
we have a lot of friends who uh um are
couples and also work together and if
you go and you talk to all of them uh
one everyone's always like asking kind
of in closed door dinners like
how do you work together and then also
like the personal stuff like not get
like have work spilled over into
personal life or vice versa or whatever
and so there's like tactical things but
i think if you went and asked every
single one of them
and like the guys and uh the women would
say the same thing of like there's
balance like the man is uh uh takes a
very specific view on something or takes
a certain approach to things uh and the
woman in the relationship takes a
different approach sometimes actually
it's like oh hey i'm like uh i'm the gas
she's the brakes we have other friends
who are like the exact opposite like
she's the gas and he's the brakes but
like the balance makes like a more
well-rounded team to some degree and i
feel like a lot of times that gets
either one ignored or two like people
don't like the fact that uh you could
identify uh oh each person has their own
strengths and you put them together
they're stronger together yeah it feels
like that has become somehow taboo in uh
in society as well yeah like men and
women aren't equal
and that is cancelled you're cancelled
you are cancelled
men and women are not equal and it's a
feature not a bug i think that they
complement each other perfectly well um
you know whether it's a woman who's more
masculine and a man that's more feminine
so she's i don't know she's the gas and
he's the break so whatever way it is it
doesn't really matter is it fair to say
that men and women are not equal on
every single like aspect and therefore
because i think what ends up happening
also i i'm very aware of uh the internet
absolutely is amazing except for in one
area
nuanced conversation is like banned from
the internet right
you cannot have nuanced conversations
that's how they get you back for more
that's the point yes exactly uh there's
a reason why it's only 280 characters um
but if you think about uh
uh let's take a basketball team
the point guard
is amazing at dribbling and passing and
calling plays and like doing all these
things
nobody in the nba is like
why is the point guard not posting up
down underneath the basket the guy who's
6 10 right or seven feet tall it's just
known like this is the role this is what
you're great at by the way the person
who plays center can't play point guard
right and and vice versa and so it's
like
strengths are very obvious but
weaknesses are very obvious
in the conversation around
gender and like roles in society and all
stuff it just feels like we want to
label everything with one broad brush we
don't want to say like no hey this
person or this type of person or this
person with this upbringing or this
training or whatever like here are their
strengths to hear their weaknesses guess
what we probably should find somebody
with the opposite strengths and
weaknesses put them together like that's
a better team
that seems like common sense but it
feels like it's completely left out of
the conversation and it's just like
equal not equal there's no like no put
these people together and they're like
stronger together yeah 100 because like
we're saying that's the only way to keep
people on the internet by not allowing
any numerous conversation and yeah
people love labels it's the best way to
help them characterize things and filter
through um information in their brains
um but i think men and women complement
each other amazingly well um and as a
woman i'm able to say certain things
that men aren't allowed to say um and i
don't do it for clicks i don't do it for
anything other than i my
brand my mission my everything is to
empower individuals to save themselves
and that's teaching women that you know
don't wait to your 30s it's teaching men
no one's going to love you
unconditionally other than your mother
you know it's teaching these really hard
realities of life whether it's
empowering somebody over their finances
their personal life their health
whatever it is um and that's sort of
what i want to push the most um
and there's so many things that i
understand like explain this more so
like you said you tell women don't wait
till you're 30 and then you tell men
nobody's gonna love you unconditionally
except for your mother start with the
woman uh comment what does that mean
so
men prefer
younger women
so like a man in his 30s is more likely
to want to partner with a woman in her
20s rather than somebody his own age
because men date down
why do they do that why do they do that
because men want to protect and provide
so it could be to some extent
off-putting a woman that's already super
successful um you know and when she's
the ceo she's probably got some
masculine traits now um whereas like a
woman in her 20s who maybe isn't an
entrepreneur and is more feminine and
you know he he can probably feel more
like a man with her it makes him feel
better in order to protect and provide
for her also there's fertility reasons
you know men may want hundreds and
hundreds of children and she's more
likely to give you that in her 20s than
she can in her 30s um everything's a
generalization obviously
and women date upwards um and all of
this is okay why do women do that
because we want someone to protect and
provide for us we women will always date
a man that's more successful and more
intelligent which is why it's hard when
you're a woman who is successful and who
is intelligent because you're like oh
wow i'm already
in the top very high percentage of
people regardless of gender so now it's
like wow like that's creating an even
smaller pool is what it is it's just the
harsh realities of life nothing to do
about it but people get so offended by
these things and i don't think you need
to be offended that men prefer younger
women because women prefer older men
when i was like 20 i would date men that
were in their late 20s and that would
offend my peers it would offend the guys
my own age and you know there's nothing
to do about that so women in their in
their 30s and 40s complaining about this
is like well girl you weren't you know
you weren't offended when you were
dating men 10 years older than you when
you were younger so that's that's the
female situation um the male situation
we kind of spoke about this it's
no one is going to love you
unconditionally other than your mother
and i know that's so harsh but it's so
true because if you're not doing your
job as a man
that's it you're done your wife is going
to leave you
but that's have been happening literally
for centuries i know but they're trying
to reverse engineer they're trying to
not let people realize that um so they
want men to
you know get fat
um don't become an entrepreneur stay in
the nine to five get into debt get in
you know enjoy the inflation because
higher wages and all this rubbish you
know they're they're trying to push
people lower and lower and lower one of
the craziest stories from history uh and
i'm gonna generalize here someone
remember all the details but marcus
aurelius uh was the emperor of rome uh
he was out on the battlefields fighting
uh one of the invading forces and uh
word got back to rome that marcus
aurelius had been killed and uh
obviously they didn't have cell phones
back then so like takes a while to get
there um and his wife uh said to their
daughter uh stay here i'm gonna go to
egypt and for those who don't understand
rome egypt egypt was where a lot of the
grain came from and things like that
a lot of land obviously
and at that time when an emperor died
the number one group of people that were
at risk were his family because the next
emperor
regardless of who they were usually
killed the family of the past emperor
because that's the way that they
establish power sometimes it was a
direct hey we know that they killed it
other times somehow they all just died
right um but what she decided to do was
she went to egypt and uh basically
marcus aurelius had kind of a right-hand
man and he had been looking over a lot
of things in egypt and as the story is
told she ended up sleeping with him and
basically like almost like uh being his
personal like hype woman being like you
could become the emperor of rome with my
backing like you can get you can go
there right now together and like we can
install you you can protect my family
and you can like have all this power and
wealth and all this stuff well
unfortunately for her marcus aurelius
was not dead word got back to him that
like yo
your wife is you know around uh and uh
uh thinks that you're dead
so uh in a number of the depictions she
basically then goes to the front lines
to go find marcus and basically be like
hey work's still good right
uh she does not come back alive and so
when you think of that uh story it's
like
man that is not the like stoic version
of the of the past that we're usually
told but
that is very much rooted in like human
nature of uh
the way the story is told that woman is
specifically looking for i am in danger
my family is in danger i need to go and
do something you can question somebody
who did something you know hundreds of
years ago sure uh thousands of years ago
um
but it feels a lot like what you're
saying now like like this has literally
been going on for thousands of years
yeah it's how women are hardwired and
you can't reverse engineer that like
like i said they're trying to make men
more feminine like you can't you just
can't reverse engineer that i'm just
never gonna be attracted to a feminine
man because one day i'll be pregnant and
i won't be able to work then i'm like
[ __ ] now who's gonna provide for me now
i'm in my most vulnerable state like i
have a child i have you know you you
need somebody to provide for you that's
why women will always date up that's
that's all you can do because
everything's about survival everything's
about evolution it's why people social
climb it's why people you know the whole
thing everything comes down to evolution
everything is about human survival um
and so even as a man dating down is so
that you can make sure that your
bloodline goes on and on and your legacy
lives on forever through all the
children you have with this younger
woman who has more time to give you more
children um
and yeah they're just trying to reverse
engineer it break down the family unit
how much of this um ultimately boils
down to uh the message that you're
delivering is uh saying hey look this is
how much this is how evolution human
nature works uh does it violate if a
woman says no i want to be the ceo i
want to be successful i am ambitious or
or whatever kind of criteria that uh i
think in some ways feminism uh stands
for like
is it still valid within the framework
that you're providing where a woman can
uh marry up or seek you know uh uh
security or something to provide for
them but also be successful as well like
are these two things at odds with each
other or can they both be true they're
both true like i'm an example of why
it's true okay i
if i if i don't make money i'm not going
to eat like it's that simple like i
don't come from money
you know my dad's not going to pay my
rent like i got i'd have to go home and
i don't i'm not going back to
back to that little town where i came
from right so like i have to make money
in order to survive right and i think a
lot of entrepreneurial women do what
they do for survival purposes um and
there's also a lot of feminism
indoctrination as well that's something
which i experienced so in
in the movies growing up it's always the
tomboy the tough girl that's celebrated
and she gets the guy it's never the
girly girl and the prom dress with the
pink and the glitter right and so when i
saw that i was like yeah i want to be
the tomboy everybody loves the tomboy
you know the cool one that plays
football that was like indoctrination in
my brain for years and years and years
it wasn't until i was in my like early
mid to mid 20s and i was like actually
that doesn't really resonate with me i
actually feel more beautiful and at
peace when i'm behaving in a more
feminine manner
so i think both are true because yes you
do have to make money um in order to
survive and you need to be an
entrepreneur in order to make survival
money you're not going to get survival
[ __ ] you kind of money if you're um if
you're in your nine to five as
somebody's assistant
so there's that but then yes they are at
odds with each other because
you become more masculine
because that's what is necessary like i
one of my videos somebody commented i
was like does she not realize she comes
across as masculine and it's like i know
but this is because i'm in a work
setting and i'm trying to get a message
out there and if i say my message in a
really sweet and loving way you know
it's not going to be as aggressive but
the the trick is to know when to turn it
off and i think that's what a lot of
women can't do um especially when you
work in an environment whereby you're in
an office and you're you are the ceo and
you've got to remain masculine and tough
in order to have everyone beneath you
including men um to respect you and
respect your authority and that
communion you're in that environment all
day every single day
that is hard to switch off that is very
very difficult and if you are with a man
and you're going to bring that kind of
energy home there's going to be a
problem um but what i've tried to do
because i'm like hyper aware of
everything too hyper aware probably um
but i try to find a balance in the way
that i portray my message the amount of
time i spend in certain energies um i
hire men to do the more masculine side
of things so like when it comes to
business i have a man that negotiates
for me um because number one he'll do
better than i will when it comes to the
negotiation number two people will
respect him more which is great and
that's okay and number three um i don't
want to get into my masculine energy i
am now i guess supposedly because like
we're having a conversation and this is
necessary but
other than that like i don't want to
spend too much time on that energy why
do you think he's a better negotiator
than you um well he's better at taking
risk than i am
and well i've seen him like [ __ ] up with
the risk before
but overall like he's better at taking
risk than me we've been in situations
where we've been offered money and i'll
be like take it take it take it and then
he'll be like leah shut the [ __ ] up we
are not taking this and then he doubles
it
right whereas i would have settled so
many situations i've seen i would have
settled
um
is that a a male female thing or is that
just an experience thing i think it's a
female thing i can get into that energy
like don't get me wrong yeah into an
energy where i can like be the best
negotiator but it requires time in your
masculine and i don't want to spend too
much time in that energy and so i and
i've done that before and now i'm like
trying to just
balance it out it's really important um
as a woman so yeah it's it's getting
that balance um and like i said i can
get in it but it you've got to be in
that for a lo for an extended period of
time so what would you say to women who
are like okay cool everything you're
saying i agree with but like dudes are
scared of me when i'm like that
but like i like i intimidate men
uh by having like the masculine energy
well calm it down just don't be
masculine in a mass company like if i if
i'm on a date or something if i'm trying
to like get a man you know get him to
like me oh i'm pleasant like i'm not i'm
pleasant now but i'm but i'm not like
this like right now i'm like aggressive
with you right i'm not going to be like
that at all ever let him lead
don't try compete with him just sit back
and i think that's one of the most
beautiful things about the male female
dynamic anyway because it's like
an opportunity for you to just switch
off and relax and like let him do what
he needs to do and he'll enjoy that more
um and the only men that i that i date
are all masculine men and they say that
i'm feminine or whatever you know like
so i i i i'm just hyper aware of the
situation and i think don't lead with
your career because you don't give a
[ __ ] like that's for starters
well a woman cares about a man's career
because she needs to know that he can
protect and provide right a man doesn't
care about a woman's career he doesn't
add anything he cares about how
nurturing you are how kind are you also
how healthy and fit are you because i
want you to raise my children that's
what he cares about again it's back to
evolution um and that's absolutely fine
of course you know a man can be like wow
i'm really amazing i love what you do
and and that's great because you know
for example me i love what i do and i'd
hope somebody would um would value what
i do and value my opinions and stuff
like that but it's not but it's not the
deal breaker you know it's not you know
it's not wow she has a podcast i must
marry her i'm more attracted to her now
no but as a man it's like wow he's got a
podcast that's hot he's successful
that's hot i want to marry him now you
know um so it's
men don't care what about uh men who say
that they want intelligent women do you
think that that's true or do you think
that they're bullshitting i think that's
true i think men that say they don't
want intelligent women are bullshitting
because
ultimately like it's a partnership and
if do you want a dumb woman raising your
children yeah
my friends who are like oh i uh like
they don't explicitly say it but like
they basically are like that's not like
the most important thing uh and
sometimes i use career as a proxy of
like um uh i i'm not so worried about
like what the career is i always just
think about the fact that like don't you
want to have friends who are smart who
are ambitious who are going to teach
your kids to do this or whatever like uh
most of my friends i'm sure there's
exceptions i won't call them out but
like most of my friends i think uh don't
want to be surrounded by like a dumb
person every day and that's on both
sides like the women don't want to be
around a dumb dude all day long and a
guy doesn't want to be around a dumb
woman all day um and so it just feels
like uh maybe people are like performing
a little bit right and they don't want
to explicitly say because they feel like
it's too harsh or like too honest which
is like a whole another thing it feels
like society in general
uh especially before the internet was
like just lied to each other like nobody
wanted to actually say the truth now
with the internet it's much easier to
say the truth um but the truth scares
the [ __ ] out of a lot of people as well
yeah the truth is terrifying yeah and
that's why andrew was banned um because
like i said we live in this like
snowflake generation whereby people
can't um process the harsh realities
that they're hearing um like i just had
my birthday which is all very exciting
being honest like another year older so
i'm just like okay like you know you
just you just think about these things
and i think that's important um and back
to the idea of like being with an
intelligent woman 100 i think a man
should be with an intelligent woman like
like what are you going to do you want
to live with this person all day you
can't have a conversation with her and i
think i mean you can i mean you're an
example of this like a man likes to
bounce his ideas off of his woman let's
build together and build something
amazing together for sure for sure i
just think like you know oh she's not
worth hundreds of millions darn it no
one of the things uh man we're gonna get
really into some topics here now that
people are gonna get mad about but uh
one of the secrets women who are
listening that just i've never
understood is i will sometimes go to a
dinner and it's all guys there and like
a guy will make a comment essentially
like yeah like this dinner was a great
excuse for me to get away from my wife
and i always am just kind of like
dude why are you married right like just
like to me i i don't know and
unfortunately it's usually like older
guys because i think that uh there was
probably um a different standard at the
time like i feel like now maybe younger
people uh we know the divorce rate has
gone up but like people who aren't happy
just like leave the relationship
and there's a bunch of negative side
effects to that but that's one of those
things that always like kind of i don't
know just like what is going on here and
then if you think also
uh my wife and i talk about this too of
like if you don't like the person that
you're married with like
what do you do every day
right like all of our friends i think
they like really enjoy being with each
other and if you ask like what they do
on the weekends or whatever like they
hang out with each other like if they go
to dinners they go together and and all
this stuff uh
but like if you don't like your
significant other
do you just like sit on the couch and
both like stare at your phone and not
talk while like the tv is playing and
like pray that they don't ask you a
question i've seen couples do that at
dinners and it's heartbreaking like
what's going on
people get married for the wrong reasons
like i could have gotten married like
two years ago but i was like no i know
i'm gonna wake up one day and be like
you're not it um people get mad for the
wrong reasons whether it's because um
like i'd say my grandma got married for
the wrong reasons like my grandparents
are amazing but she got married for the
wrong reason she got married in 1951 or
something like that and it's because
she needed to
get out the house she needed a man to
provide for her and that was it and they
got married were they incredibly happy i
don't know i think grandma could have
been happier
but it's people just marry for the wrong
reasons um and that is why it's good
nowadays and why i would tell women like
you know secretly like yeah make sure
you've got your own money like you know
you don't want to be stuck with somebody
um so i do like modern times to an
extent because it has um allowed us
number one to see how the previous
generations messed it up um and also
as women we are more empowered now and
so we can choose we don't have to just
pick the first man that comes to save us
like i've been in certain situations and
been like yeah if this was the 50s i
would have married you but i'm not going
to um money in relationships is really
interesting because uh i think a lot of
people
uh
for decades and decades and decades it
was like okay get married like everyone
puts their finances all together and
it's like hey there's one big account
for the household or whatever it's a
business yeah to some degree without a
doubt and then there's almost this like
whisper network i think of women started
to like uh
talk about like hey make sure you have
almost like a secret bank account like
have your own money you know be able to
have some level of uh resilience
but i actually think that like the
default in every relationship
there would be less
com like uh uh um like conflict and less
uh arguments if
people said hey there's actually three
bank accounts
like each person in the relationship has
their own bank account and there's a
shared bank account and guess what like
you can do whatever the hell you want
with your own money and then like the
shared money like people figure out how
to do that and to me um
if people know that money is the number
one driver of arguments and ultimately
of divorce
like just solve the problem up front
when everything's like good so that you
never get in those situations but for
some reason there ends up being this
like uh uh no one can like say that
right it feels like that is like not the
way that it's allowed to be talked about
it has to be like oh you should have
your own money because like you know god
forbid anything ever happens like why
can't we as a society just come out and
say like hey people argue over money
money's really dumb and like people who
love each other literally will get
divorced over money like just solve the
problem upfront and prepare to be in a
situation where you can drastically
reduce the number of arguments in the
future the same way we talk about there
should be financial literacy in schools
should there be like marriage literacy
in schools
how to like
how to like
navigate relationships like how to be
emotionally resilient how to have a
conversation without without bringing
the other person down rather than saying
you know i like
i don't like i don't you know i don't
like you because you did this rather
than saying i don't like how you did
that so it's like pointing at the
problem rather than the person
that would be really useful but that's
like conflict resolution that you can
use in marriage in business in your
interpersonal like relationship like all
these different things that you can do
but for some reason we don't teach that
at all so people just don't know that
but then two is like
because of the emotional component of
marriage like it just gets exasperated
even more and then people have a hard
time of being able to say like you were
right i was wrong
i think it would be really useful
financial literacy and uh mental
resilience emotional resilience and how
to negotiate right i had chris voss on
my show the other day and he's so cool
because he talks about hostage
negotiation but then he brings it to
business
and then i'm pretty sure he brings it to
relationships and the guy that i that i
mentioned earlier that does a lot of my
um negotiating for me he even says to me
like leia you he's like you don't know
this because you're a woman so you don't
you don't have to think like this
because like as a man when i'm like out
trying to get a woman you know i'm
praying or whatever um you've got to
behave in a certain way and he's like
that negotiation between a man and a
woman is the same in business like play
hard to get you know something so simple
like but it's a memetic response again
it goes back to human nature like this
has been going on for thousands and
thousands of years
of every human wants what they can't
have yes
and why would you make yourself too
available for somebody um when they
haven't done anything for you because
then you become suspicious right
so and i an example of this is like a
male feminist like that creeps me out
why are you a male feminist now i'm
suspicious of you right like i haven't
done anything for you you don't know me
and you're like trying to fight my
battles that i don't even have like that
makes me suspicious if a man comes on
too strong i'm suspicious there's this
guy that lives in my building that won't
stop texting me i'm like
i'm like
i'm like this is too much how did he get
your number don't even ask that's
another that's another conversation
yeah that's another conversation but he
invited me on a yacht right and then he
invited and he was going to like cook me
this big curl so he's going to get a
chef to cook this big korean dinner on a
yacht right i'm not going
i'm not that bloody hungry but isn't
that like the amazing date that a bunch
of women would want why would he give
that to me what have i done for him i
don't deserve it yet
what if i'm a piece of [ __ ] what if i'm
boring what if i like why would because
of how i look
now you're now i'm like oh this guy only
wants to have sex with me because he
doesn't know anything else about me
other than the way that i look um and so
he's doing too much
what am i doing for you everything's
about exchange like what am i doing for
you nothing you know maybe
okay like i said i just had my birthday
maybe if we'd been dating for like nine
months or whatever and he wants to do
that on my birthday i'll be like damn
let's go thanks babe you know because
i've been such a great girlfriend so
here's a great treat you know um but
that makes me suspicious of him and so
now i'm really not answering his text
message does it work the other way like
are there things that women can do that
men should be suspicious of
yeah not in the same way um that's a
good question actually i need to think
about that i think there are red flags
um and i think there are things that men
should be what would be the red flags
i don't think a woman can ever give a
man too much in the beginning
um especially if he's like successful
and high value and all this rubbish you
know i think you know she sees something
good and she's like pick me please she
likes him which is fine i think there
are red flags like if she's trying to
compete with you you know and if she's
trying to like um
emasculate you and disrespect you in
public
um you know just insult you um fight
with everything you're saying if she
doesn't want to help you you know make
your life easier those things are red
flags but in terms of like coming on too
strong i think in general anyone can
come on too strong but i don't but i
don't think there's that same like be
suspicious of her
as like the other way around
i have a lot of friends uh thankfully
they've been uh very successful so i get
to just hang out with them um but uh
those that are single
they're deathly afraid of actually
meeting somebody who they like
because they're suspicious because
people will figure out that they're
successful and then they don't know uh
whether it's because they're successful
or because they really like them and i
find it fascinating to talk to them and
you know kind of every couple of months
or whatever we'll be at dinner hey you
know what's going on with the with the
love life and uh yeah they uh they
have a very very hard time because uh
they feel like every single person they
meet is there for the wrong reasons and
so it goes back to like are you better
off actually meeting somebody earlier in
your life rather than later in your life
and you can go to the extreme of like if
you're like a 55 year old man who's a
billionaire
i don't know how successful your dating
life is going to be you know to find
somebody who you can fall in love with
for the rest of your life uh maybe you
get lucky because you only got like 20
years left that you can make it 20 years
yeah but like i do think that some of
those dynamics play into it where uh
it's a psychological thing that people
end up uh almost like talking themselves
out of uh because they're so scared it's
a really good point um tell me if i'm
wrong but this is the way i would look
at it um if you're that successful as a
man and you've been and you've been able
to make that much money then that must
come with a certain level of
intelligence um and self-awareness and
so i think
it should be easy to suss somebody out i
think the same way you can suss out they
like they lie that's what they do the
girls they like no no no they're the
guys they guys they lie they basically
when they meet somebody they not lie
about their name or anything but they'll
lie about like what they do
right and like they'll like almost like
downplays it goes back to a lot of
things in life um uh actually my wife
told me this one time and i thought it
was really good and i'm gonna screw it
up but she'll give me [ __ ] about but
like basically the idea of when you
haven't made it yet you you uh try to
play up everything right if you like
read the um
if you read the bio of a speaker and
there and it's 17 pages long you're like
you might be full of [ __ ] right yeah but
then if you read the bio of somebody
who's hyper successful
it's like nothing same as what they wear
right yes because when you're not
successful you play up and you wear the
gold uh chains and and you uh drive the
fancy car and they do all these
different things and then almost like
you reach a certain point of success and
then like it goes opposite and they like
downplay now that doesn't mean that they
don't own a fancy car or they don't have
a mansion or a yacht or whatever but
it's a different like uh kind of i don't
know uh way of
exuding the wealth
and so intelligence is also the same way
success is the same way in terms of when
they meet people like how many times do
you hear stories of um somebody is uh
hyper successful they meet somebody and
then they leave the dinner and they're
like i didn't know that that per like oh
my god i had no clue and it's like in
some way you ascribe more value more
status to that person who downplayed it
rather than the person who's sitting
there the entire dinner and they're
telling you about how amazing they are
and everyone's like dude shut the [ __ ]
up 100 there's a there's a networking um
association or whatever in miami and um
i met a guy and he is like a super rich
bitcoiner like i'm talking early early
early days he then built a company sold
it for like hundreds and hundreds of
millions this guy is done he doesn't
even work right
he is so chill i had no idea i'm sitting
next to him he's and he's also a
socialist as well and i was like bro
i was like
you know it was cool until that part
yeah he's lovely and being a socialist
in miami has to be like a death sentence
essentially because there are so many of
you from latin america who are like
we've seen this experiment it does not
work yeah literally that's why i love it
but no 100 it's also like when people
put in their bio like as seen on cnbc
i'm like
don't do that and something which i do
on the side as well is um i help like
coach people with their social media and
branding and marketing and stuff like
that and i always tell them for their
bios on twitter just keep it very clean
very basic that's it don't hype yourself
up remain somewhat of a mystery well
it's um they're playing the status game
obviously
which uh everyone does uh to some degree
but i do think that it's interesting of
like the rise and then at some point
there's a tipping point yes and like
then it becomes like downplaying a lot
of different things which um
again uh i think dating as somebody who
is uh young and not yet successful
versus somebody who is older and
successful are two completely different
games and people just don't talk about
it i don't know there's so many things
that i i feel like i have conversations
with friends in private that i'm like
why don't people just talk about this
stuff like it seems so weird they people
don't talk about anything there's so
much we should talk like people should
talk about but the the thing about
downplaying as a man i spoke to somebody
about this the other day he was 28 and i
said to him i was like don't downplay it
too much like you know don't don't like
uh underestimate um the way a woman is
hardwired she needs to know that you can
protect and provide
you know especially somebody like me
like i need to know when the apocalypse
comes you know when like when they tell
you if you're gonna take that injection
you're fired i need to know that like
you're fine you don't need to take the
injection and you don't you know you can
leave your nine to five right um so
don't downplay it too much but yeah of
course like
you don't need to say like i have
hundreds and hundreds of millions and
all this stuff um i think that's a
really fine line um but i do think your
friends like surely should just know
what a woman's after and it's it's i
mean especially miami shots you usually
be shocked at how many of them well they
like eventually they they uh can flush
it out but like
i've got friends who have dated a girl
for six nine twelve months and then like
oh
what was what what was it how did you
notice like uh you usually um it almost
feels like uh uh they weren't after
something other than like the person and
then like it just becomes obvious over
time it's usually not like oh i had a
conversation she said some magic word
and like now i'm out uh it's usually you
know like in many relationships i think
that uh um everyone always thinks about
uh people in relationships grow apart
but also like friends grow apart
and so um i have this theory that
uh there's only really two ways that
people end up together uh in a
relationship for a long period of time
tell me it's either uh you meet like
very early in life so
high school or college maybe
and you meet at the same uh like status
level to some degree and then what you
do is uh you evolve together so uh you
go through
college graduation together your first
jobs together your first uh promotions
bonuses you start a company whatever the
thing is but like you you do that
together and you successfully navigate
all of those changes in your life
together because you're both going
through them at the same time and for
whatever reason you're able to do that
successfully the only other way that
relationships really work is like you
both have your own paths and at some
point you meet down the road after
you've both had some level of success
because what i think ends up happening
is that uh one the people who meet in
high school in college like it becomes
obvious hey we can't navigate all these
evolutions together so like those
couples break up uh but also people who
meet and somebody is like super
successful earlier in their career than
the other person a lot of times those
relationships don't work because uh it
goes back to like when you go home
who do you talk to you talk to your
significant other and like
i always think about like how many bad
decisions in the world happen because
people are asking their significant
other who knows nothing about the
situation or about the industry or
whatever for advice
like most people probably should not be
asking their spouse for advice on like
what to do at work if uh you're a
corporate america uh like executive and
she is a entrepreneur running like a
small business on main street
i don't know how much
overlap there is right like should it be
like uh a small business owner calling
up a mckinsey consultant and being like
hey what should i do with my business
you're probably gonna get bad advice
also the mckinsey consultant calling up
the small businesses i'm like hey we're
trying to do this tax thing like small
business is like i don't know i just
call my accountant right so it is like
who you ask for advice is almost as
important as the advice you get but
uh it goes back to these relationships
and like
i don't know picking the right person to
spend time with who you're probably
spend the most time with is probably
top one two decisions you make in your
life 100
and it's hard like you tell me how did
you know your wife was the one
uh i we pretty much knew almost
immediately but as soon as you met
for the most part yeah that's what i
think is true but but like when we met
uh the very first conversation we had um
there was a number of things that i
don't know if she's comfortable with me
sharing uh but um there's a number of
things that we talked about that it was
just like very obvious like oh this
person and i think very similarly uh we
have similar ambitions and uh
um there was like a mutual respect but
also this like uh similar attitude of
like um
anything that happens in the future like
there's a way to figure it out and like
you can do that with somebody else so
it's just like a whole bunch of things
and and it's not like oh we're gonna get
married one day and we're gonna have
kids and like
anybody who says that like you're just a
egotistical arrogant amazing hilarious
yeah uh uh bullshitter
but like i respect the [ __ ] out of the
[ __ ] um
but i think what
is obvious is like hey this person is
someone i want to spend a lot more time
with yeah and then it like evolves over
time into like okay like uh
we've now done this for a year now two
years or you know whatever and then
eventually it's like oh okay like yes i
have de-risked the situation yeah which
no one likes to talk about it that way
but like i have de-risked this situation
where my confidence level has gone
because i always um
uh what there's all these shows now uh
if you're like scrolling through netflix
and it's like you know get married on
the first date or like uh arranged
marriage or this or that you're like
what is the probability that those two
people end up being happy like near zero
but somebody who's dating even if it's
for six months twelve months two years
whatever like you should have higher
probability uh of success and higher
confidence in your decision making if
you have many more data points
that's all dating really is i love the
fact that you said that you knew
straight away because i think that is
true i think it's i don't know how old
you were when you guys met but i think
you get to a certain point um or an age
or whatever where you meet someone
you're like i just know like you just
know um so i'm always like stressing i
forget who it is it might be algorithms
uh to live by or super forecasters i
can't remember which book uh i read them
both at the same time so i can't
remember which one it was in um but in
one of those books they talk about this
idea of uh
you should if you if you have an unknown
number of uh options
basically what you should do is once
you've uh looked at i think it's 33 or
50 percent of camera i think it might be
33 once you've looked at 33 of the
options you should pick the next best
one
so like if you looked at 33
of your options
the next thing you see like this is
great
you have enough of like a baseline to
compare it against yeah where like you
probably have a pretty high degree of
confidence in your decision making
but you don't wait till you see all you
know 100 of the options and then like
[ __ ] yeah option 42 was the one i should
have went with yeah and then you have
like regret and so it's this fascinating
thing around like human psychology of
like
a lot of people don't get married at 18.
you know some people do but for the most
part people don't and so they've
probably dated or been on dates or
talked to a bunch of people
25 26 27 years old somewhere in that
range they have enough of like a
baseline of okay here's the things i
like things i don't like here's the the
experiences i like the type of person i
like whatever like and then they
basically pick
and the picking is a double opt-in
that's the other thing people forget
okay it's not just like we don't live in
in america we don't live in a society
where like people are like
that one but it feels like that it feels
like you get no come on no no no in
terms of what you were saying though
because like you have this baseline
right so you know what you like and what
you don't like
but
once you have all that information
you'll just you see it yeah but how many
times does somebody pick but somebody if
somebody picks and the other person's
like nah that's not for me so the double
opt-in is both people are saying oh i
see yeah hey yes this is for me and so
it ends up leading the reason why it's
so fascinating is because i actually
think uh a part of the conversation that
a lot of people haven't had is when uh
the pandemic happened yeah
most people look to their significant
other
for health advice
for personal safety
for should we move should we not like
all these things
and i have a lot of friends
uh who um or use pregnant women my wife
was pregnant uh uh during this and so uh
obviously there was a lot more thought
process that goes into just not like hey
what are her and i gonna do but also
like there's a baby and what are all
science all this stuff uh we're not
scientists so like you know doing our
best here uh we called a bunch of people
like did all stuff
but we have friends who are pregnant and
like
they just like got in line and we're
like let's go
together together yeah let's get the
shot and then we were like
hey did you even look like i don't like
the conclusion doesn't matter as much as
the process
and they were like oh maybe i should
have like wow like researched more or
like thought and i was like by the way
like your decision is your decision like
whatever i'm not here to like be
prescriptive to anybody
but you didn't even like do any research
yeah for all you know it could be
absolutely disastrous for a child or
could not be
but you don't know
and that's when i realized i was like
holy [ __ ] critical thinking is
absolutely non-existent in [ __ ]
society because
the mainstream narrative just dominates
absolutely the mainstream narrative is
aggressive and it's almost impossible to
fight this episode is brought to you by
eight sleep good sleep is a game changer
and the eight sleep pod is the best
sleep machine i sleep on it every single
night a great night of sleep allows you
to be healthier be more arrested and
have more energy throughout the day and
on the brand new 8 sleep pod 3 you can
sleep as cold as 55 degrees fahrenheit
or as hot as 110 degrees fahrenheit
that's the secret of thermoregulation
better sleep better energy get yourself
innate sleep you can go to asleep.com
pomp today to go ahead and get 150 off
your order
8sleep.com not only do i sleep on it
every night it literally changed my life
and i begged the founders to let me
invest in the company
8sleep.com go get yourself an 8 sleep
pod and get a better night of sleep um
the whole thing with covid was
mind-blowing like i had a friend um she
came over to my house and was um and was
genuinely like arguing with me about how
like it's dangerous and you know she
doesn't want to pass something onto her
parents and i'm like why are you here
then like the lack of the the cognitive
dissonance that people can't quite
understand you know like my body my
choice for abortion but then when it
comes to vaccines it's not your body
sorry it's your body my choice you know
but you're allowed to say that yeah if
men said that no i'm not
i might be like i don't know i got like
so much hate when i said vaccines my my
body my choice um the cognitive
dissonance that we saw over the last two
years was absolutely mind-blowing and
actually um my whole life has like
changed because of that why like i am
now prepare every choice that i make
is with the idea in mind that tyranny is
right around the corner so like i said
i'm jewish and growing up um in europe
um
we were always told um holocaust
survivors were always told to have your
bags packed because you never know
when something's coming right always
have your bags packed um and i never
really like internalize that because i'm
just like well i'm happy here in england
everything's good it wasn't until
covered that that mentality really
really made sense now every decision i
make moving forward is knowing that
tyranny is right around the corner so
when i pick a partner it's like can you
flee with me are you my apocalypse
partner like i said when the when they
tell you take the medicine like how are
you gonna navigate that can you think
critically to actually see that this
could be potentially dangerous or did
you just get it out of convenience and
you didn't even think about it you know
because that's a red flag so every
decision i make where i'm living how i
you know do my finances holding bitcoin
everything that i do is knowing that
tyranny is right around the corner and
so i always prepare accordingly yeah i
do think a lot about process versus
outcome and uh
people who make decisions whether they
work or not are there good decisions bad
decisions in hindsight uh how many of
them actually have the rigor to think
through um all of their options and then
make a highly calculated high
probability decision and what scares me
is that that number is not very high
like if you look at society in general
um
five percent maybe maybe if we're lucky
right well it's because humans are um
will always take the easy path we always
take the path of least resistance and so
we will never wake up to certain
realities until um we are physically in
pain i think it was euro bezmanov that
said you will not know that you are that
you are um that you are being
manipulated you will not know that
society is being demoralized you will
not know that you are literally living
under tyranny until you're on your way
to the gas chambers that's the only way
you will know and i think the same thing
is true for covert and the vaccines it's
like you took that thing without even
thinking about it right i think today i
saw the next booster is now available
but that um but they won't put but that
hasn't got finished human trials um so
that's clearly dangerous um but you
won't know until like
maybe you can't get pregnant maybe you
can't have children maybe you have
health issues maybe as a man you now
have a heart problem you won't know
until you're physically in pain because
that's how the human mind works i also
think it's like a defense mechanism as
well because
it's like leaving the matrix it's too
painful
to realize that everything is a scam
everything is orchestrated you know
whether it's the financial system
feminism the war and masculinity like
you don't know that all of this is
orchestrated until you physically feel
it um and you don't want to wake up to
that like i know i know people who are
like in their 60s and you know they
thought that you know the nine to five
and giving your life to the man was a
good idea and it's too painful to pull
them out um which is why like we are so
privileged to be in this era whereby we
actually have access to alternative
information i think like my rabbit hole
with all of this started probably with
jordan peterson because he's a very kind
of um
a relatable approachable individual
because he wears a three-piece suit like
you said you know he's a doctor a
professor you trust him um and so yeah
that is uh information that i would
never have had access to if i was born
in like the 50s the 60s whenever it was
and so with that mindset yeah i can i
can at an early age know the truth but
you hit a certain age and it's too hard
to come out of the matrix i have a
framework i call it the modern day
[ __ ] meter oh yeah and the best way
to do this is there's three questions
that you ask
when somebody tells you something you
say why
they then say
usually some appeal to expertise or a
kind of status they'll say because so
and so said it and then you say uh
uh prove it so it's why
says who prove it
and you can apply this across almost
every aspect of your life just somebody
says something why says who prove it and
what you find is by asking those three
simple questions
a very large portion of the things that
you're told you immediately are like
i think i need to do more research on
this because that sounds like [ __ ]
and
what's scary about it is actually
very foundational things to our life
that we previously thought were true
now all of a sudden it's not so much
that we like over rotate to like what
i'll call like the conspiracy theory
land and it's like oh my god everyone's
like got some plot to like kill us all
or whatever
but it's just that like man this thing
that i took as fact actually there's a
lot of gray or there's a lot of nuance
here that i wish that i had known years
ago and so whether it's around food
around exercise whether it's around
information you read on the internet
whatever it's just why says who prove it
and it is scary how many things you end
up
i've changed my mind or i now believe a
watered-down version of what i believed
or whatever but like why don't we teach
that in school
i think it's i think if you can change
your mind after receiving more
information you are a genius and a great
person but so many people can't do that
um and there are people that i see on on
twitter that have said crazy crazy
things which kind of leads me to
actually a
side point which i actually want to get
your opinion on um a lot of people say
you know what we're talking about is how
bitcoin is feel right this is like a
very bitcoin kind of conversation do you
feel that there's um like this divide
and a political divide so like bitcoin
is tend to be more right-wing or
libertarian and then when you see that
that random person who's like
pro-vaccine and they're a bitcoiner
you're just like i don't understand you
do you does that confuse you um i i
don't think we can paint a broad brush
across all bitcoiners because i think
there's bitcoins on the right there's
bitcoins on the left there's bitcoins
independent libertarian all these
different like political parties what i
would say is uh uh i actually think of
bitcoin less as like a political
kind of box and it's more about critical
thinking and now what ends up happening
is uh
what you find in the political parties
is that there's like the dogma like
almost like a religious like fervor of
just uh whoever is the source of the the
dogma like i will follow them no matter
what uh and then there's the critical
thinkers and i always ask the folks in
the political world uh one question i
can quickly put them in are you dogma or
are you a critical thinker it's what is
one thing that the other side believes
that you agree with oh that's a good
question and you either either have
something or you don't by the way it
doesn't even matter if it's like a big
thing a small thing whatever but the
people who are like they're wrong about
everything you're like you're insane
like you literally this is now not about
intellectual uh humility or uh uh
honesty it's now become a religion and
so if you just say like okay uh in the
political world there are definitely
people who lean on one of these axes but
they do critically think and they can
say you know what i actually think that
uh i agree with this or maybe my
political party and this political party
agree on it mm-hmm like that kind of
screws people up so when i think of the
bitcoin world like that's all it is it's
just like people who think critically um
and by the way like bitcoins are wrong
about stuff all the time right i'm wrong
about stuff all the time you're wrong
about stuff all the time like that is
human nature nobody is right 100 of the
time
but it goes back to process versus
outcome if you can focus on the process
and say to somebody i don't care what
the actual end decision you made was did
you have the right process to think
through from a critical standpoint uh to
not get swayed by the mainstream
narrative to have the courage and
conviction to be independent uh in your
thought process and analysis and then
do you just have a good decision making
framework like a lot of times uh when
i'm talking like a founder i'll say to
them hey why'd you do that and they'll
like come up with some crazy reason why
and i'm like okay walk me through like
what were the options and why did you
decide that and what i'm trying to get
at is like what was the framework used
to make the decision
and more times than i wish that were
just true they're just like
went with my gut
and like by the way like intuition is
actually the uh totality of all of our
experiences and like all these things
we've learned and whatever it's like
there's some like science to it
but like
why didn't you look at this data set you
have or why don't you talk to this
expert that you know or this or whatever
and then you just realize that like no
in their head they've categorized
decisions and this is a low value or not
important decision so they didn't spend
a bunch of time on it which maybe
they're right maybe they're not but the
high value decisions they go and they
create all these reports and you know
analysis and all stuff
so you start to like try to unpack this
and you just realize like good
decision-making is probably one of the
key
skills for adults to have but also to
teach children like we talked about
earlier and if you look at
everywhere a kid goes
outside of their parents if their
parents really care about this stuff
they get zero critical thinking
education
none so like we shouldn't be surprised
that nobody can do it in society they
would never teach critical thinking in
school school literally empowers you to
be this obedient
individual you know like we have to i
don't know what it's like in america but
in england and we weren't allowed to
just sit down you know we had to ask to
sit down we had to be told you don't
have this uh i haven't been to school in
a while so maybe
but yeah we could just chill no no we
use oh my god well firstly we wear
school uniforms right so immediately
we're in suits everyone uh across the
the country wears a uniform a public or
private school yes until you get to
uh 16 and uh 17 18 the last two years
you can wear what you want um because
you're an adult now um but um yeah so
you walk in and you stand behind your
chair
and then the teacher says you may now
sit down and then we sit down
interesting you don't have that in
america uh i'm sure there's some schools
that do it but like definitely not in
the public schools uh you can wear
pretty much whatever i mean there's some
dress code uh how long you know dresses
can be or
uh i don't think guys can wear like
sleeveless shirts and stuff like that
but for the most part there's like a
dress code but you can wear whatever you
want um and then uh
most classrooms
are there's zero chance that there's any
degree of like order
really
well you have to remember like
how if you are uh i'm a huge
generalization but if you are a
50 year old teacher yeah you've been
doing it for 25 years
and uh you have a kid who's just an
[ __ ] like just
they're disorderly they're constantly
talking they're causing problems like
all this stuff
yeah are you worried about the smart
person that's like very well behaved
standing behind their chair and then
waiting to be asked to sit down like no
you're like
everyone sit down and shut up yeah right
like here's the lesson plan here's
whatever and so like i feel for teachers
because it to me is like almost an
impossible task uh i actually know
someone who's a teacher and and every
time i hear them talk about like the
classroom everything i'm just like
dude you
this is like the most important job in
america
the problem is that you're a teacher
plus a babysitter yeah right like you're
a disciplinarian as well and so much of
the energy and focus goes the
disciplinarian component rather than the
teaching component and so naturally like
the kids that want to learn who aren't a
problem
they're not getting a hundred percent of
the teacher on the teaching side they're
watching their teachers spend on 10
minutes out of a 50-minute class
disciplining people creating order you
know passing your sheet like all this
crazy stuff
it's an absolute mess yeah i mean i i
didn't know that in america it's not as
like strict or ordered as it is in
england but i think i think the rules
still sort of stands they don't teach
you critical thinking no financial
literacy you have to ask to go to the
bathroom you have to ask for all these
things um there's some of that like you
you have to ask in most schools you have
to ask the bathroom or whatever but
remember america was built on like the
revolution yeah right and to some degree
uh immigration and like the rebellion
the the the ability to uh uh to some
degree uh make decisions for yourself
seek a better life like there are some
components of america that i think are
different than other countries um
but there's still a lot of the same
things around just like yeah like it's
built for the industrial age to control
people make them obedient put them in
factories
and like it's done a pretty good job of
that until we didn't need those people
anymore and now we need people who can
think critically and and you know make
their own path
we have a critical thinking crisis i
think the last two years literally just
proved that and i wonder if we'll get to
a point whereby people um will start to
wake up i think covert was an incredible
opportunity for people to wake up i
actually think donald trump's presidency
was an incredible opportunity for people
to wake up i think actually donald trump
was the turning point for me personally
um
in sort of realizing that we live in a
snowflake generation um the most
funniest thing that he said was
if you're rich and you're a star women
will let you grab them by the [ __ ]
right that to me was such a turning
point that statement i did not expect
you to say that okay yeah that that
statement why it's so fascinating
because it's true
and the fact that we can't have an
honest and a nuanced conversation me
saying it's true is not nuanced but the
fact that we can't have an honest
conversation about that
blew my mind are you saying that donald
trump andrew tate jordan peterson
i love all these messages
like they're all saying the same thing
they're all saying the same thing
because it's true like look at any rich
charismatic successful uh strong high
status man
women will flock to him not all women
that's not really something that i would
do and a lot of my friends would not
really like that but most women will do
that look at miami i every time i go out
in miami there's always a 60 year old
man on a date with an 18 year old girl
okay
she'll let him
he doesn't mean you can just grab her
without her consent that's not what it
means it just means that when you're
successful women you can have your
choice of women and it was the fact that
society was so
um
aggravated by that unable to
take it in in the spirit that it was
meant because it was meant in a certain
spirit because it wasn't said on stage
or said in the locker room talk like
context um that for me was such a wake
up um is it good for society to operate
that way uh yes i think because um
free speech matters
um and i think no no the free the free
speech thing
let's just say they could say whatever
they yes whatever they want to say
whether you agree with them or not like
that's the whole point of free speech
but like for that to be true which i
think we've said over time uh for
thousands and thousands of years there's
been this uh dynamic but like
is it good for a society to operate that
way
i think that
it's okay because there's because
everything's consensual you can grab her
by the [ __ ] i believe doesn't actually
mean grab any woman because you are
entitled to her it doesn't mean that
that like that it means she will let you
you know when you're a star she will let
you um how can you police that anyway
how can you police the fact that young
girls like rich men older men how do you
police that you can't and i don't think
it's bad um in terms of like the
language i know you weren't really
asking about that but in terms of the
language like i don't even think that
should be police either because like if
that offends you good toughen up you
know um so
that for me was a turning point
massively actually uh donald trump
does it feel like um the political
discourse in america is different than
in the uk or elsewhere or is this the
same thing it's a great question because
um unfortunately americanization is real
and um we have severe americanization in
the uk so in america things are far more
um heated and aggravated okay um you
have like you you identify by your nat
by by your by your ethnicity and where
you come from italian-american uh
african-american um irish whatever we
don't do that so already you have this
divide right it's not we are one we're
american you already have the divine in
england if you're black you're black if
you're white you're white i don't say
i'm jewish english you know
no i'm english and that's it and so
already you so the difference there is
like you have that divide now during the
whole blm thing um what was going on in
america was insane and it actually broke
my heart to start to see that come to
the uk so we saw black and white people
at it um in in london and that's not
that's not an english thing we never
have that if you're black great for
white great like of course you know
racism exists in all societies and of
course there are white people who are
awful black people are awful whatever
but we don't have that racial um that
aggravated racial tension thank you yeah
we don't have that like you have it um
and americanization is is is is real and
especially in terms of like feminism and
stuff like that like a lot of that was
was born here
much of that was born here you know like
the abortion debates
all of that was born here like we don't
have that in england you know we don't
have like these um
these um
like political topics which are what are
they called you know when um like pre
like election topics which swing an
election like abortion guns yep what's
that called like just like a hot like
the hot topic or the the uh there's a
name for it where it's like a like it's
like a top anyway you know what i mean
um we don't have that like abortion is
not like a single voter issue
single-voice issues yeah um so um
abortion is is not a single voter issue
like we don't have any of this divide in
england but it's coming
like i gave my views on roe versus wade
and i had my dms
flooded with english people english
girls that i went to school with they
were so outraged by by stuff that i'd
posted about it and i'm like incredible
we we would never debate this
this is an american issue which has
resulted in me falling out with my
english friends
so we weren't originally like that yeah
what do you and your friends talk about
like in private such a good question i
don't have many um
friends anymore english friends anymore
um because of the way i am um
entrepreneurial i'm critical thinking
not a feminist um so i don't actually
have many friends anymore but we talk a
lot about the ones that i do have we
talk about men you know women talk about
men a lot we talk about um like what
about like like men that uh you guys are
interacting with on a day-to-day basis
like celebrities like
about celebrities no no we'll talk about
um
like
what we're looking for in a man like
what kind of men we like
i don't know we'll talk about like we'll
talk a lot about politics like i'm
really into this kind of stuff so i'll
talk about this stuff with my friends
um and they engage and are interested as
well
i'd like is i don't have many friends i
have very very few friends um i
celebrated my birthday like i said the
other day a year ago
i had one friend at dinner with me one
friend on my birthday because the rest
can't handle who i am now
um i'm only in my 20s so it's not like
i've had years and years like a lot of
the time we're friends with people who
we um who we've been um who we happen to
be with because of circumstances in
school so we were put together and i've
never worked a normal job i've always
just hustled basically so i've never
been able to make
friends like colleagues like that right
um so all the friends if you think the
school friends are fickle the work
friends are probably even more fit i
know i know well it's true it's true but
but i i can tell the difference between
you're you're a work friend and like
you're a friend you know um so we talk a
lot about each other's lives you know
helping each other how's your day what
are you going through that's what we
talk about um i don't i never talk about
like kardashians yeah i love islands and
all that
and then how different do you think your
conversations are than like uh i don't
know a group of woke women such a again
amazing question so i had a friend that
i used to be very friendly with and i
used to say to she's a teacher and i
used to say to her um
so in september next year when the
school year um you know when it comes
like
what are you doing are you gonna like
become the psychologist you said you
always wanted to be are you moving um so
i asked her about her future i asked um
a question which was about growth and
development she asked me do you remember
when we were in school in the lunch hall
and we were and you know remember when
that guy threw that piece of paper and
it was so funny
that's the difference there's no like
growth mindset i don't even think woke
people are complaining all day like i
don't think they're sitting amongst
their feminist friends and being like
the patriarchy is getting us i just i
just don't think they care about the
same things that i care about like the
last two years unfortunately i've spoken
a lot about like tyranny um and things
like that um but overall you know
they're talking about probably more more
fun light-hearted things i guess yeah
they're talking about the past i'm
talking about the future it is something
that i notice uh there are certain
people in your life that you come across
and uh they very much are still stuck in
uh things that happened in the past um
and uh things that they accomplished in
the past and all that and there's some
people you meet that are very forward uh
focused and uh when i was younger i
probably had a more black and white view
of it of like uh
looking in the past is bad looking to
the future is good now i think i've uh
evolved those thoughts to just be like
are they happy
and
whether it's somebody who looks to the
future or somebody who looks to the past
like they may be happy doing that and if
they're happy doing that's like amazing
right like that is actually the right
answer and uh it goes back to this idea
of like um company culture
some cultures uh people think are like
that's a good culture that's a bad
culture well you find out uh as you see
more and more companies is like there's
no such thing as good or bad culture
it's all about a fit between the
employee and the culture so why is it
that there's a certain culture some
people are like i absolutely love it
that's the best place i've ever worked
and other people like that place was
hell i hate it
how could those two things be true it's
because it's about the fit it's not
about good company or uh uh culture or
bad company culture same thing with the
way people look at the future versus the
past like it's just what do you what do
you find the most enjoyment in i think
the part that uh is scary and sad to
some degree is the people who are not
happy and look in the past yes then
you're like oh like just you know just
be happy like like pursue the happiness
rather than pursue the like memories uh
but for the people who are happy doing
that then like knock themselves out
right speaking of company culture though
um and what work people talk about so i
used to work as a journalist in london
and um that was toxic
because they were all woke um and i was
only 21 at the time so i didn't know
about like woke i didn't know that i was
so set in this mindset i didn't know who
the hell i was i just felt away um and
do you know that you know the actor
henry cavill i've heard yes he plays
superman very attractive and um he lives
or lived around the corner from where
our offices were okay um and um somebody
had said oh i saw henry cavill on the
streets the other day and uh one of the
girls like i hate him this is the one
that i mentioned earlier that was like
i'm not shaving right so she was like i
hate him and i was like oh why because
of his comments about the metoo campaign
and she's just like yes leia and you
don't think that's bad how dare you are
the biggest like oh i was like whoa what
did he say
he said that um the metoo campaign made
him feel like he couldn't pursue a woman
anymore and he's like excuse me for
having you know old-fashioned
traditional values but i think a woman
should be conquered conquered and
pursued and he believes in courtship um
and i totally agree so he said he feels
like now he'll be accused of like sexual
harassment because we're so sensitive
and so this girl in an office
environment went after me and not one of
the like senior leadership in that room
said a thing nobody said anything it was
okay to come after me um verbally
because you know i wasn't woke and i
want to defend something that i was the
craziest thing you saw inside of a media
organization uh oh wow i've got such a
good story for you so i was in paris um
and i was working for the chinese and i
yeah exactly so i was working for the
chinese and um i went to cover an event
um it was the huawei event 5g
and i was interviewing a chinese person
from
huawei and i wasn't allowed to say
certain things and do certain things and
i and i had all these uh chinese people
around me
watching so you and i are in here right
now just us imagine if we had all these
people in here censoring and watching
every question you asked and i was like
wow like this is this is like uh
censorship in real time um and it was
only allowed to be a fluff piece and i
wanted to ask about like i think they'd
been like blacklisted in in america and
i was gonna ask them you know do why was
that you know why why were you
blacklisted in america why would you
why are you okay in europe you know i
was really i wasn't allowed to ask
anything um it had to be a fluff piece
um so that blew my mind another thing
that blew my mind as well
there was an israel-palestine um
um
conflict yeah and protests in england in
london and i had to like edit the clips
to like overlay for the news um and i
and i and i felt as i was sitting there
i felt this power i was like wow like i
can really manipulate how this story is
portrayed
um
and i was like wow i can i can do that
because i have all this footage and i'm
like i could pick the israel one first
if i wanted of them crying then i could
pick you know and i could literally
manipulate how the story goes out so
that really blew my mind yeah it feels
like uh inside of a lot of these
organizations um it's kind of like a
college
so
when people are on a college campus like
that is the universe to some degree and
the people who start to look outside of
the universe first uh university first
they end up um being in a uh um
a different place right like mentally so
like most people on a college campus
where they worry about like classes uh
kind of all the social [ __ ] uh
parties like all that type of stuff and
like if you have that one friend who's
like no man there's like this big world
out there after we graduate and you're
like like dude lighten up like have some
fun right like whatever uh so like it's
a very self-encompassing environment and
people get very sucked into it and then
when you like leave after like two or
three years you're like
who cares right but you had to like get
out of it to some degree media companies
i think are very similar in that like
inside of the media company they think
that their media company no matter which
one you go to is the most important one
and it's this like big amazing cool
thing and then like when they leave i
think they realize like oh nobody
believes that [ __ ] like literally
nobody in the real world is like this is
the truth they just are like that's one
set of content creators competing with
the rest of the content creators on the
internet and so i've talked to a lot of
uh journalists uh two
big secrets right now in the media world
it's like a bunch of them are leaving
and some of them have like openly left
but there's a bunch that are considered
the like
standard bearers of the traditional
media like they are out
they've already like talked about quiet
quitting
they've already quit
they're just waiting to see like what is
the move that they can make from a
career perspective that will put them in
a good position but like
if you sit down and grab coffee with
them like they'll just tell you this
place is [ __ ]
complete [ __ ] nonsense going on in
here uh everything from the woke stuff
to a censorship
knowingly sharing misinformation like
also and like you're talking to someone
you're like
am i being recorded like yeah this is a
prank i thought that you were like
inside the beast and like a piece of the
machinery like no and by the way like
all my co-workers they think the same
thing just like we don't know what else
to do
and so i think that the pendulum
swinging on the media is going to be one
of these things where people are going
to realize like
wait a second
even the media the people who uh helped
to really propagate a lot of this stuff
over the last couple of years
even they're like almost getting like
red pill to some degree and uh inflation
is the canary in the coal mine oh really
why do all of a sudden there's tons of
inflation articles about how inflation
is a problem or uh the bureau of labor
statistics only has certain people and
they're manually going and getting and
everything because guess who's getting
[ __ ] by inflation
the journalists they get paid nothing
and they are getting paid in cash they
have no equity they have no investments
they have no they're literally by their
job they are not allowed to make
investments they are trapped in cash and
the cash is being eroded away at
historic rate
guess what their [ __ ] weapon of
discourse is they get out their computer
and they start writing articles and
they're like [ __ ] these people
and so in some way like that is the red
pilling of the mainstream media is
literally inflation is eating away at
the journalists who cannot have
investable assets it's so fascinating to
say that because i met a journalist at
the bitcoin conference um i would say
who obviously i met her at the bitcoin
conference and she was asking me
so like how do you make money
they're all
what do you do like are you comfortable
on your own like you can say what you
want and i'm like why i thought you were
like the [ __ ] like you you're not happy
and she's just like
not really and that honestly was so
fascinating i think it's also just like
the rise of social media like social
media now is is different to how it was
two years ago it's evolving just because
we had it back in like
2014 13 doesn't mean it is what it is
today um and also
with with this with social media and the
information i spoke about there's
there's like this new teaching of how to
make money um you know smart work
instead of hard work like that is the
concept which i'm new to it's i heard
that for the first time when i was like
23 or 24 even i don't know like two
years ago or something like that not
when i was like growing up in school i'd
never heard about smart work um so this
kind of entrepreneurial um business um
uh content is waking people up globally
like i do so much smart work i don't
work hard i work smart um i work hard
when i want to i'm but smart all the
time and yeah so these journalists are
waking up to that i'm realizing like oh
i could have my own show i could have
sponsors i could do this i could do that
um and they also do feel censored as
well um and
money as well they're not allowed to
invest how much do you think my wife uh
when she started a major media uh
company how much do you think she was
paid she was like two or three years out
of school
she's publicly said it's all repeated
okay i i haven't heard it so it's
probably different as well wages are
higher in america which is what i've
realized compared to england i didn't
know that um that would probably in
england that would be like 24 000 pounds
a year which is what like 27 000 a year
or something like that i don't know it's
pretty close yeah like 30 grand yeah
right and she was living in new york
city and she was like wow whoa yeah
right and then over time obviously as
they go up and then like you know the
editors or the executives or whatever
they get paid lots of money and so uh
it's fascinating to see um
you know these are people who uh
in some ways you feel for them right
because you're like look uh
they're doing the thing that they
thought they wanted to do in life
they're not getting paid very well uh
and a lot of them
don't care about the [ __ ] now some
of them
are [ __ ] making the [ __ ] right uh
and it's pretty obvious i think to see
who is who because uh if you work at one
of these major corporations for more
than like five years in today's day and
age like you have just become uh for the
most part unless you're an investigative
journalist or a war correspondent
outside of those like you're pretty much
a mouthpiece yeah 100 and i i think like
the whole nine to five situation in
general is going to decline like
covet again it works so many people up
even you know remote work that's not
something which people really considered
or thought about before covert now
everyone's like oh i could work remote
before remote work was like this luxury
now it's like becoming more of a
convenience and a normality social media
everything everyone's making content
everyone is making content once you
realize that most journalists
are just content creators on the
internet
all of a sudden like the playing field
is
equal it's level and they're all
competing for the audience's time and
attention it's the attention economy by
the way you're also competing with
spotify [ __ ] netflix and youtube
right but like everyone's competing and
uh
just because you have some big
corporation's name on the door nobody
gives a [ __ ] anymore the the audience
does not care and you see it in the
numbers yeah joe rogan was the most
hilarious example they're so they're so
full of themselves these major news
organizations and corporations that they
can't even fathom that we don't care
about you anymore they don't understand
why rogan would get millions and
millions and millions of views they they
don't get it because they're so far gone
and so up there and asked exclusively
excuse my language that they just they
don't get it um and for us it's it's so
obvious it's like you're a mouthpiece
you're repeating the same thing um you
all say the same rubbish i mean remember
the headline inflation is great why
higher wages it's all [ __ ] there's
no real conversation everything is
censored um and i love that they just
don't understand why nobody cares about
them i don't remember the exact numbers
but the last number that i heard from
the new york times is they had five
million paying subscribers
there's a lot right five million people
who are paying them money every single
month or year
daily wire which is ben shapiro they now
have jordan peterson stuff had uh as of
the last number i saw publicly about 900
000 paying members wow
so if you look at that let's just say
that those are ballpark numbers
daily wire which most people don't even
know the [ __ ] that is
has one-fifth of the paying subscribers
that the new york times has
if you need any other data point to show
the world is changing and like the power
is shifting
like the new york times been around for
100 years
daily wire how old was that a few years
six years
you know whatever 10 years like whatever
let's say they're around for 20 years
yeah like it's just a whole different
game going on and so it just feels like
um
uh
i'm always careful that like
the machine like literally rage against
the machine the individuals for the most
part i think are actually good
intentioned hard working like trying to
do the right thing there are some bad
apples for sure that uh make big issues
but like
it's the machine
and actually what we've seen is some of
the greatest independent voices used to
be inside the machine than they left
and so like a lot of the people in the
machine now they're just like the future
great independent voices it's just like
break them out like just convince them
to leave i know and i wonder how far
this is gonna go like i don't know what
the future looks like um
and i don't know i think those that are
awoke are gonna stay woke like if you
haven't woken up woken up in the last
two years then you're you're staying
asleep so i feel like there's going to
be this um two kind of system society
you know where you have like the the
florida and texas and then the other
rest of america this this society
whereby you have these two opposing kind
of um people some that want to take
personal responsibility the others that
don't want to take any responsibility
and want to push
ridiculous agendas like drag queen story
hour they're gonna like
work parallel side by side and i don't
know physically how that's even gonna
work because like
are we just gonna keep going backwards
and forwards with this pendulum or is
like a civil war gonna break out and you
know florida really does break off or
not or you know we will move to el
salvador because el salvador is the only
place which actually put out some honest
content about uh coven and how to
recover from it i don't know whether
we'll start literally voting with our
feet and leaving um so many amazing
people that i know have left america
because they just say it's just become
it's just become you know to the state
has become too big it's too involved in
your own life so i don't know
what do you think
i'm not gonna leave uh at least for the
foreseeable future uh i still think that
there's hope that it can like get back
on track uh in a lot of different ways
um but it's a lot of work to do yeah
like and i think that's part of it is uh
i recently tweeted and i said uh this is
the super bowl for entrepreneurs
especially in america we have so many
problems we have to re-shore
manufacturing and supply chains and
transition from an industrial age to a
digital age like do all these things
like who's going to solve the problems
but can america do that because i feel
like the current administration are
actively making things worse like on
purpose i feel like
they do things the greatest companies in
the world are still in america by far
and uh that's despite
the friction the headwinds like all that
stuff uh which one is a testament to the
entrepreneurs and the companies that
that have been successful uh and then
two is i think there's a pendulum
swinging on the political side where uh
people are starting to realize like wait
a second um you know in some ways tupac
was uh
like they got money for wars but they
don't have money to feed the poor like
how did how's that possible yeah right
and uh again there's tons of new ones
tons of complexity tons of
generalizations that go into all this
stuff but uh
there's a lot of problems around the
world we seem worried about when like
let's fix our own [ __ ] yeah why did they
give so much money to ukraine
you have to ask them that question and
every time someone's asked them they
have a different answer that's what i
mean so like the system like biden is
the system he is the administration and
for me there's just too many red flags
too many weird things like the message
they put out over the whole vaccine
thing like wishing death to the
unvaccinated what is that like why are
you pushing so much um you're so much
divisive language um why are you wishing
death upon unvaccinated people why are
you not empowering people to go to the
gym eat healthy what's going on with
bill gates buying all the farmland like
there's so much weird [ __ ] going on
right now and i don't i don't know
whether i just i just read books yeah
and chill and try not to uh worry about
it too much
yeah you can do that but you because you
have an amazing setup because you're
you're you're set up for i'm not gonna
get i'm not gonna uh get pressured from
uh from anyone but like i just
at some point you just to be like man
there's a lot of stuff out there i can't
control it's wild
uh i want to understand
but uh i don't trick myself into
thinking that uh i'm gonna change
some of it but the things that i can
control like let me go focus on that
stuff yeah that's the only way before i
let you go uh tell us about your book uh
we haven't talked about it at all no
it's not good but but uh but to everyone
uh
i'm addressing bitcoin um i launched
that um i published it a year ago nearly
um and it's basically a really easy
guide to understanding bitcoin um it's
kind of for the people who want to know
about bitcoin but they feel overwhelmed
and intimidated by all the uh major
books out there so it's a very concise
really easy language and it's just like
an amazing starting point to learning
about bitcoin um it's very up to date
with everything that's going on even you
know down to like el salvador it talks
about the technicalities of the bitcoin
network how that works um how um it
hedges against inflation um deflationary
asset um and all these things and also
like politically why it's good so from
like a freedom standpoint um so i kind
of talk about you know like free um
fleeing tyranny um you know always
having your bags packed like i said
earlier
um and so
um yeah it's it's it's um i'm really
happy about it you know i'm happy that i
did it i'm happy that that it's out
there and i think it's an amazing way to
get into bitcoin it's on amazon um
there's a kindle version there's an
audio version um and yeah it's a super
easy read awesome and uh where can we
send people to find you on the internet
so i'm on twitter i'm on youtube and
instagram and also tick tock actually um
so it's just my first and my my last
name leia heil pen um yeah so please
come over and
i talk about all this stuff constantly
basically so if you like this you'll
like the rest absolutely i appreciate it
very much we'll definitely do it again
in the future thanks so much for having
me it's been so brilliant